[Music]
i'm now joined by douglas murray
and we're going to be talking about
freedom and where the british people
actually wanted
douglas you in your brilliant column
this week you talk about how
there was an expectation that the 2020s
were going to be the roaring 20s
and in fact what you say is that they're
going to become the boring 2020s
what do you mean by that uh yes
this refers to something i actually
referred to in a column earlier this
year as well
nick christakis distinguished the
american academic
made headlines in a way that american
academics tend not to
across the uk earlier this year when he
he said
in pouncing that that perhaps the 2020s
would be like the 1920s
a great roaring decade and that just
as the the 1920s
were this great roaring decade following
the great war
so perhaps after the corona era
we would have this great roaring uh
party decade of
the 2020s and i of course
there's a reason why the media and
everyone else wanted to pick up on that
it's a sort of terrific story it's a
great claim
and it's uh for a lot of people anyway
it's something to look forward to
i pointed out by the way when i last
mentioned this story that
uh there's an obvious problem with it
which is that for most people the 1920s
weren't all that
roaring uh for a relatively small
segment of society they were
um but for most people they just had to
get on with their jobs with their lives
they weren't all the cocktail parties
and the bright young things
and of course the whole decade ended in
a crash
so um i wasn't at all sure that i wanted
uh the the 2020s to be roaring like that
um and if it was going to be one great
big orgy
then i suspect as always that the
benefits would accrue to a very
relatively small number of people that
most people wouldn't get a look in
um however yes i i've just expanded on
this
in my column this week really to make
a bit of a wider point which is that uh
there has been a feeling i think
uh through the pandemic but once once we
sort of got
through it we were really gonna live
again you know
people were really just going to want to
get out there they were going to want to
do all the things they hadn't been
allowed to do
you know the the horrible 18 months
we've had
perhaps longer would be forgotten
and made up for and actually as i say in
my column i think the signs
are rather in the opposite direction
all the polls show a very significant
chunk of the british public
who don't they don't even want to mew
let alone raw quite happy
staying home in the garden
for the rest of their lives want that
even if all the restrictions
are lifted and even if all of the
measurements to meet those restrictions
are met
and then you've got the other cultural
issues the other the other wider issues
which uh particularly i mentioned in the
column
is this very strange early warning a
sign that we already have
of the extraordinary program that's
being shown to anyone who is sort of
wanting to get back
out there there's a deep sniffiness in
the air particularly in britain
a sort of sniffiness of the people
wanting to get back
out there particularly and i think this
is one of the most
unsettling things the deep sniffiness
about young people wanting to get back
out
there and i think this in particular is
quite wrong and must be resisted
is it something that's getting worse
because i mean i think there's always
been a sort of undercurrent of suspicion
of
fun in britain where we were we came
from puritanism after all
and i suppose from what i what i got
from your piece is that perhaps what
what's happened is we're reverting to
what we were before which is a
a nation of people who don't really
trust people being outdoors and enjoying
themselves
uh we're suspicious of of public
pleasure
yes that's right i always think of that
great h.l menken quote about puritanism
he defined puritanism famously as the
sneaking
fear that someone somewhere was having
fun
um there's a great streak of this in
britain always has been
and i think it's been exacerbated in the
last year because although we may not
have the puritan religion we have the
version of it that replaces god with the
nhs
for instance you know that you are you
are risking the nhs
by having fun uh you are failing to do
your bit
to protect the great national
institution and their great national
deity
that you're being um selfish by enjoying
yourself and going out
and and as i say that in particular this
is likely to push a generational divide
that's already there
and generational divides already exist
but a generational divide that's
particularly there on
in the case of this virus um because
what young people i'm in my 40s now so i
don't think i count as that anymore but
but what young people in their late
teens and 20s
uh have had to give up in the last
18 months is very significant
they have been as i say in the piece
they have
been forced to for instance if their
students study alone
many of them have lived alone they've
missed the opportunity to meet their
peers
they've been told unless they're in a
stable relationship
to be monogamous to be not just
monogamous but actually to be
chased the government has told them
to be virgins or to at least engage in
two years of chastity
uh they have if they've followed the
rules they've
they've done that i'm not sure how many
have incidentally but
but if they follow the rules they've
done that they've these this is a
generation that has missed a significant
amount of its
lives and its opportunities to meet
friends to meet partners they've
they've studied alone they've run up
student debts alone they have graduated
alone
and i don't at all blame them that they
now want to get out there for a virus
that as can't be said often enough has
almost no effect has almost a negligible
effect
on people of their age group so this
great demand has been made of them
and i think there's this lingering sense
that they should as it were
keep staying at home even though we have
had the vaccine
now the vaccine that by any
standard should be the passport out of
this
terrible ghastly era even after that
there's this sniffiness that they would
want to go out
to these large-scale events and i think
it's
i think it's cruel i think it's
unusually cruel
and i i think that all the sort of
adults engaging in that sniffiness
should really
should really think about that i suppose
it's crueler than
puritanism in many ways or any kind of
theocratic thinking because it's
they're not saying to to people uh you
know you
don't uh sort of indulge your voices
because it's bad for you
they're saying don't do it because you
might harm someone else
yes that's right you might harm the nhs
you'll put the nhs under strain
and you'll kill other people uh as i say
when we get back to this thing either
the vaccine is the way out or it isn't
and uh um if it's the way out then life
has got to return to normal
and i i do for my own observation
keep noticing that it's britain
that seems to be worse than recognizing
this
you know the americans do seem to
realize i've made this comparison in a
number of places
the americans do seem to realize you
know once the vaccines in
you know you make your choice about
whether you take it or not uh but then
you just get
but get back out there and the british
don't seem to have
taken that view um i mean partly because
the government
very very misguidedly uh suggested
earlier this year that the vaccine
wasn't why
cases had fallen and that actually it
was locked down
but you know if the vaccine isn't the
way out then there is no way out of this
um and i think that's something that the
british in particular have got to focus
on but yes
you're right there is this there is this
sort of as we see in the public health
campaigns of recent uh weeks and months
where people are
you know being shown scary images of
people dying and basically tell
this would be something you'd cause if
you were to flout the rules is
is a form of coercion which is not just
ugly but untrue
well uh perhaps the martyr of your piece
if i could use that word
is charlie perry uh the football fan
who uh stuck a red flare up his bottom
and lit it
um and it was a sort of uh viral
sensation the video of it was a viral
sensation
and he received enormous amounts of
program and
uh sort of disgust really um and
that very much speaks to what you're
saying that we are um appalled at the
idea that someone
would go out and behave irresponsibly in
in a way that
british people might have been in the
50s yes i mean i
i should stress charlie berry is a
slightly unusual hero um
and um but nevertheless it's important
to get
this this right yes as you say mr perry
is a
25 year old roofer who was
very excited i think we can say that
about
the england final in the euros
playing against italy and mr perry came
to some national notoriety in britain we
should we should stress this for our
international viewers
uh mr perry came to some notoriety
indeed made the front page of a number
of newspapers
because um on the relevant match day
um he he he went large as you might say
he he drank he thinks about 20 cans of
cider which is
it is quite a lot and
uh he also managed to get into the
ground for free
by jigging his way in about it they call
it uh
and so he was absolutely thrilled by the
whole day
couldn't have been happier and and
expressed this happiness in in
some ways a traditional way by
taking his trousers down in trafalgar's
in leicester square sorry
leicester square uh taking his trousers
down shoving a
flare up his backside and lighting it
and
it may not be how you or i would
celebrate
uh um england reaching the finals of the
euros but
but for mr perry it seemed to be uh the
uh
the just the uh the the the
just the ticket and um
he he actually said this the press after
uh vilifying him they caught up with him
and he said in an interview you know
he's just thought that after 18 months
uh really miserable months he thought
the people needed a bit of cheering up
so it was a sort of public service in a
way in mr perry's mind
he certainly saw it that way and um and
of course it is a dangerous thing to do
and we should stress in case there are
any children watching
that this is not advisable mr perry
didn't actually
feel uh fortunately the sparks
from the flare in his anus because uh he
drunk 20 cans of cider
and if if you're going to avoid
it turns out the the back flare
of of of a flare
20 cans of cider is your well necessary
precursor
but there are there are better ways of
letting off steam is what we will need
to
yes and sparks and so so mr perry
um did this and what was interesting
about it was that this
is this is to my mind i mean as i say
you and i may not
may not favor this sort of form of
celebration but but
but this is pretty much what i expect of
england
football fans it's the sort of thing
they do and the crowd in leicester
square was absolutely thrilled
uh it went down very well among his
his friends and his newly acquired
friends it was just the nation as a
whole that reacted with this
universal program to it which i just
thought was rather interesting because
i don't think he should be a national
hero um
but nor should he be regarded as a sort
of national villain
and there was this complete across the
media there was this
this thing of um what a terrible thing
to do what an awful example to set
um what does this tell us about our
nation
what sort of image does this send out
and i just say that this reaction is an
example of something
which we've seen as well in the reaction
to young people going out to night clubs
since monday this general sort of sense
that i don't like these
things and therefore these things are
wrong
and my own view is that you know
within the limits of the law if you
don't like things
don't do them um and
don't be around people who do them i
mean you know
don't don't go to leicester square on a
match day
when you know it's going to be full of
lagged up football louds
um trying to set light to their
backsides so
you know just just just just you know
sort of one of the principles of a
tolerant society
is is that you let people do things that
you wouldn't yourself
do so long as they're within the law
[Music]
you